how are you doing clearly you're a
survivor
you're clearly I can make that known to
the world
[Music]
Ruth challenge me so you know you have
to do wait a minute you had a smoke
machine you had like it was worked out
well but here's the thing I was actually
on a photo shoot the day I got the
challenge so it was easy for me to like
okay let's whip it up I was on a fitness
photo shoot okay that explains Chad's
right behind you okay Chad is this true
that Halle just said look I don't know
when you're gonna make this movie but
I'm gonna be in it no matter what okay
explain the me-tv in her movie I
wouldn't do it because I'm a John Wick's
Ann and I heard that he was looking to
cast a female a badass female I wanted
to be with you didn't say you said it
will be me I couldn't kick her out of
the office when Halle Berry shows up
with your office and says I'm gonna be
in your movie you just shake your head
and say it okay right no you jump up and
down and say okay nothing's ever just a
conversation so what was it like working
with her because in getting physical and
doing what will it be like some people
you have to convince to get off the
bench other people you had to sit down
on the bench
she was definitely you got to take a
break
unrelenting unrelenting my god she wore
out to stunt teams
speaking of unrelenting the picture you
posted of your abs recently why are you
doing that to the Internet
why cuz Chad got me in the best shape of
my life so why not show it I mean you
got it want it
worked me so hard I never worked so hard
in my whole life for this little
character in this movie and I've never
been in the best shape of my life
mentally physically and it's all because
I got to work with some of the best of
the best and so you know that they're
they're you know wonderful benefits of
that but it is a little terrifying when
Halle Berry says I'm in the best shape
of my life when you're like Halle
Berry's been in the best shape of her
life her whole life alright what's it
like working with directors now that you
are a director and you direct to do you
sometimes see yep what I'm bout to yes
are you ready I am ready yes that's
gonna help you can't get her back to a
trailer no she's got a stance that she's
always watching always learning always
there you never had to look for Halle
Berry on set it was their great director
you know nobody knows action better than
Chad he has sort of redefined in my
opinion and in many people's opinion
what the action movie is all about it's
real live action real people doing real
things which real people can relate to
you know
and he's redefined that and because he
is an action star himself he understands
what you on the other side of the camera
goes through understands the commitment
that
you know the time that it takes like so
he's a very benevolent before you go
give us one secret of what you did to
get into the best shape of your life one
secret I worked with Chad like I worked
with the best of the buds
that's my secret that's my secret she
doesn't quit and cares like you and
believe passion you want it you'll get
it
[Applause]
[Music]